[Music]
so lebron james's son is getting a lot
of backlash on social media ronnie
barely yeah ronnie why did he sucks at
basketball
[Laughter]
i mean you wouldn't be the one you would
think
actually being bad at basketball would
probably make a lot more sense than this
he's getting [ __ ] because he took a
white girl to prom what
what's wrong with that oh this you know
we're living in a time where it's not
right
it's not white if you're right
it's your son it's his son yeah
you know all the black people up in arms
it's not white why'd you take a black
girl they're not allowed to date outside
the culture or something is it like a
rule yeah it's forbidden right yeah
you know some cultures like that like i
didn't know if there was something in
like black culture or whatever but i
know like um especially asians dude like
they'll be like well they don't say it
out loud but they're like
man like why are you not dating a
chinese or japanese or whatever in 2022
though yeah online
that's crazy well it's like we went
backwards though yeah it's like we went
backwards it's like you know when you
talk about like interracial stuff like
that going back to where i tell you my
experience growing up and the bail is
different you know i have filipino
homies that would date black girls in
800 points that's what i you know what
north cal north cal so mixed yeah
because you go to sacramento san
francisco everyone chills man my asian
pop what's up my [ __ ] yeah it's it's
dude it's not nobody like hey you can't
sit dude mexican homie everybody is
family vallejo rich man i've seen some
dudes with cornrows homie straight fro
he's straight laos you know what i mean
it's a really tight have you noticed
that though in socal it's way more
segregated man it's okay it's getting
dude they were tripping the trip like
what are you doing talking to the
mexicans i'm like dude that dude from
sacramento we cool oh man i'm gonna do
it and then when dudes see me from
downtown like big hurry you're different
man you're cool man but i can't talk to
you because of homies but you're cool
because i don't grow up like that like
hatred in my heart because you're a
mexican or you're you're white or this i
didn't grow up like that but that's what
they're pushing because the divide it
keeps people in control so if they can
make it seem like oh you this and that
man when you like somebody i didn't say
oh i like you because dude you're you're
a cool yellow or you're a cool brown
yeah you're cool thanks man
it's like dude you're a good dude divide
the energy you don't pick and say i'ma
wait for a black one to come along
but there are people that do though you
know what i mean
there are people i'm throwing this
yellow tail back
it's funny because everyone is giving
him [ __ ] and saying why can't he end up
with a with a black woman like lebron
did and then they pulled up lebron's
prom photo he had a white date too
oh man you know but i get the same [ __ ]
they call me a [ __ ] oh man you coming
your white wife you know i get it all
the time big hurt you tell me you're for
the black people but you got a white
woman
damn i can't have a white woman be down
for trying to help you guys yeah you
know i mean who said that about you man
i'll get them
it's so it's so bad man just a mentality
but yeah that's the mentality that they
like to have us and they don't want us
to have conversations like me and her
kicking with you guys you know oh i
wouldn't you know why are you kicking it
with them dude
who what difference does it make if i
have mutual interest i'm not gonna kick
with you and all you do is someone
robbing somebody
like people you know you're robbing me
you gotta rob me you know what i mean
[ __ ] so i gotta hang out with you
because you're but you're talking robin
yeah you know oh i'm gonna rob him man
you're not robbing my partner all right
i got so it's just like make come on
make sense yeah you you you're you're
hate you're gonna naturally gravitate
around people who have the same energy
vibration
viewpoints in life and and goals right
now i'm not gonna like go somewhere and
try to say you're my people
man get on the ground give me your watch
probably mom you're my people man come
on man
yeah i don't care dude you're aiming for
my hood i do told him you ain't dude he
from you ain't from l.a you ain't from
here so what is it what do you gotta do
with anything exactly yeah but if
somebody has your back it doesn't matter
it's about like where we see stuff
because people tell me all the time oh
big hurt we just need to separate we
can't function with them
what are you talking about bro you don't
even function with him anyways
you know did anyone ever try to jack you
outside of prison like never that's
never happened never never got jacked
you know i'm always conscious of like
when i go out in public too and like
like distance and and people getting too
close and and just watching people at
the same time and uh but i've never i
mean i've had people talk [ __ ] oh i
catch you man blah blah blah blah blah
in public on the comments
you go comment warriors you know what
man i never growing up talk [ __ ] to
anybody on the phone
i'll [ __ ] you up remember that skit
remember that skit where they're like
you want to talk some [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah he gets the highlight bro yeah oh
my gosh
you see what they do on clubhouse right
everybody talks [ __ ] i'm big zone so in
the fbi it's like okay big song so what
do you say he's gonna kill this dude
okay watch him
hey
dude who talks [ __ ] like that that's
women right that's god isn't that like
the soap operas men don't talk [ __ ] you
handle business that's it it's all on
site i'm not gonna say no i'm not going
to say nothing but like to be talking
[ __ ] it's like dude who does that
people want to incriminate themselves
like the funniest thing right is like so
like when people want to act hard on
camera because they're like oh we got to
represent and i'm like you're stupid
like why do you want to show that you're
actually willing to hurt somebody or do
something because then the cops have
evidence yeah you prime suspect number
one the best thing to do is act like a
[ __ ] yeah i love that dude he's bestie
to be like oh no i don't want to fight
no that's not me i'm a peaceful person
yeah act completely opposite who you
really are and then it's like well if if
things happen then they don't look at
you and that's the stupidest thing it's
like i've seen a picture everything dude
on instagram this dude has a rocket
launcher dude you know they instantly
went to his house he's on instagram you
ever seen that oh i do that he's like oh
man i just got this i'm like dude is
that a real rocket launcher who to buy
that from yeah
dude he's not posting like this
they're like oh you got he comments the
thousand column look at the comments
dude atf was like oh my god dude they
hashtag atf
hashtag that's how stupid these dudes
are my
i don't get it man do you think how did
what do you think changed to make
something like lebron sunday white girl
like
such a big deal today versus like 10
years ago well for one he's in calabasas
so maybe this the culture i grew up when
i when i went to high school in
huntington beach i was busting a lot of
chicks when i lived in sacramento a lot
of girls because northern cali is
different i moved to orange county
totally different
me and my little asian partner we are
only two minorities there you know we
kicked them in my vietnamese only we
were best friends but it was hard to get
a date
all white girls you know what i mean
that was huntington beach in the 80s or
90s and because
80 taking all your chicks
yeah it was way it was way more racist
back then yeah it was very like there
was an asian guy his dad had a lot of
money so he was cool he got to date a
girl but i didn't live in the harbor so
huntington's like harbor if you're
harbor black cool you know but and i
didn't grow up there so i was an
outsider so it was kind of like i
couldn't even find a white girl because
and not go to their house like you think
about this is gonna be antiquated that
picture of her with that black guy who
is this black guy
gene went to you know janine went to
prom with so it was hard
so but it was crazy
the day of graduation
10 white girls gave me their numbers
because it was summertime day of
graduation what dude it's like i've
never seen you before hey what are you
doing and you're just like where were
you this entire time i've been dry all
this yeah
no it was a great summer though
i'm like dude it's crazy because it's
like so i understand and because like
naturally if you're around that you're
going to be looking and you know to me
if you see attraction it's not like if i
see a pretty agent i mean i you know
boom this doesn't matter asian white
it's pretty but on saturday
that's true
so you're not going to go like the
inglewood to go get a prom date
you know i didn't know people still did
that [ __ ] though why don't you date your
own kind but just during that they're
stirring that up again because they want
to keep us like you know
there's a big thing right now where like
even like a lot of black women like by
the time if you're not involved in
relationship by the time you hit like
your thirties they figured the odds of
you being single for rest your life or
like over like 80 wow
just like how it's structured and how
like men are dating black men being
outside they raised and now they're
starting to like see like those other
options and you know and they've you
know a lot of them blamed on the
kardashians well they could they
would black women could date outside
their race too they could date whoever
they could but they always say oh i want
a strong black man blah blah blah blah
but then you know they get you [ __ ] did
you clean the house where'd you how much
money you made i make more to you
so it's a lot of dude it's really like
how much you made a lot of [ __ ] so when
you're up and coming you know typically
the black women might make more
initially but then like you know you
make she made good money but you know
you drive trucks you might get money but
oh you're a truck you have no status
your truck driver you know this and that
so it's all [ __ ] money driving trucks
though you make some
yeah but i'm saying as far as like
status yeah like going on public like oh
you know
so it's a lot of that where it's
backfiring now because now there's less
men you got brothers going down to
panama getting panamanian women they're
going over here to vietnam getting
vietnamese i mean they're doing other
type of type of options yeah yeah
worldwide you know down south is a
little bit different you you don't you
have a lot of like when i went to
detroit in different place like that
it's different though you don't have the
intermixing like that oh really no you
don't have it's different because of how
that set up only the only when you on
those in a lot of those states it's at
college where you might have that you
know how to make the athletes and stuff
like that but like typically like if
you're in like you know alabama
different places you don't see a lot of
the inner racial stuff going on as much
which you know i would say because of
the west coast and how
more mixed it is diverse it's just
different like how we get down in
northern california i haven't seen that
anywhere else that's true yeah northern
california is super mixed that's true
yeah but baltimore i knew guys in
baltimore they've never talked to a
white girl never had an asian friend
they've never even had interaction with
a white person on the street that's
crazy that's pretty crazy where's
baltimore uh maryland oh so maryland is
like totally different bro it's like
damn i mean i like to talk to dudes down
south and they'd be like
like oh man we've never been over here
i'm like dude they're in a bubble for
real yeah so culturally we're so much
more advanced because we're in a bubble
too out here really we're in a bubble
but we're an educated bubble where
you're having conversations it's a mixed
problem yeah so we're we're so much far
ahead like literally
just articulating just with you guys
here i can tell you're probably
our our public school system is probably
equivalent to almost like they're
private yeah
in certain areas orange county certain
areas you know because of just how how
it is it's from lausd bro i was damn i
went through some [ __ ] up schooling
[Music]
you